when the world has stopped laughing at
us for the farcical state of our
political leadership
it can start pitting us for the state of
our future prospects
Sajid Javid is the most popular
replacement for Therese May his polling
is the healthy - 18 percent Boris
Johnson who really could replace her is
that - 35 % around the same level as
Jeremy Corbyn only one in four think the
Labour leader is doing a good job others
sadly can't revel in our dismal options
for too long because many of them are in
the same mess Emmanuel Makarov may be
backing down but only after protesters
set Paris and the president's
credibility ablaze Donald Trump is
facing allegations with the most serious
security and criminal implications
populace around the world of making
promises they can't keep
I'll be really incapable in advanced
democracies of producing political
leaders of both hope and integrity
where are the inspiring new characters
set to forge ahead with unity and
progress it's really too much to ask so
I agree with you I which is very
surprising for me but I do agree with
you and in the last election so last
year I found myself in a situation where
I had nobody to vote for and I ran for
politics myself for election myself as
you know the experience that I had was
deeply unpleasant it was not a nice
experience and if a general election was
called tomorrow I'm not sure that I
would stand again and one of the
problems is when you look at how we
treat politicians in this country when
you say where are all the inspiring you
know people with integrity and all the
rest of it why aren't they sitting in
the wings sitting there going ah know
what I'll do I'll get into politics
tomorrow who would want to in this
current climate if you're successful in
the real world why would you stay at
home and go I know what I want to do I
want to get in team yeah take a day take
a load of hassle and I said Smee I'll
take a load of hassle get a load of
grief why would you want to do that
and I think that people are so they are
getting increasingly disengaged with
politics because people don't seem so
I'm politically homeless I don't have
anyone that would represent me I don't
have anyone to vote for in the next
election and so many people are like
that but we need to look at how are we
treating politicians why aren't people
being held to their manifesto promises
because this is where a lot of the
disillusionment comes from because you
say all kind of promises you get voted
in and then you just do anything that
you say that you will do and how do we
inspire those people I don't know the
outcome to that I wish I did I just want
to and before I bring everyone else in
because for me there's also this element
of post truth at the moment that
politicians just seem to be saying
whatever even though they know it's not
gonna happen look at this this is in the
last week I watched Minister saying that
this vote would definitely happen one
after the other just have a little look
my understanding is that we'll have a
vote on Tuesday and we are looking to
win that vote will be voting tomorrow
evening on the withdrawal agreement and
that withdrawal agreement allows us to
leave the European Union we went ahead
and held the vote tomorrow the deal
would be rejected by a significant
margin we will therefore defer the vote
scheduled for tomorrow
and not proceed to divide the house at
this time you know for me Michelle that
just speaks to exactly what you're
saying just this disillusionment that I
think people don't trust politicians
they don't believe what they say and
it's not an appealing it's not an
appealing prospect for somebody who does
want to say what they mean and do what
they would say why would you want to
enter that space but I also just want to
ask you a question Michelle because
you're a woman and you're also from
working on you're from a working-class
background I know you what you voted
brexit and you're Pro brexit but for me
when I'm looking at the current debate
it feels very much like a certain cohort
or very elite public school educated men
running this kind of Punch and Judy show
and I feel that if you have a woman for
working-class background or frankly just
not eat and educated you would look at
that and be doubly put off do you think
that that's a factor at the moment as
well yes I do and but I will say
something that's probably quite
controversial a lot of the treatment
that I got that was poor treatment came
from female politicians that I was
standing against so if that makes sense
so I would like to see when I watch p.m.
cues and stuff I feel put off I like to
hear northern voices when I hear
northern voices in Parliament I do and
like that might sound odd to you but it
makes me feel when someone's Navon
they've got northern accent it makes me
feel like I instant I might not always
agree with them but I instantly connect
you can't nobody like me I don't connect
Coronation Street would that be better
for you I think that you're being quiet
undermining some my point and my point
is a good one if I say so myself
but a lot of you I'll be the judge a lot
of viewers will resonate with me there
is not enough representation of
working-class northern people in
Parliament and throughout public life I
don't think anyway so when you do hear a
voice like that you do connect to it is
an interesting clip I'll show you from a
vet Cooper who stood against you know
who stood against Corbin for the
leadership this week saying what this
week had done to to the view of British
politics is worth seeing does she not
realize how
chaotic and ridiculous this makes and
given the importance of trust and
credibility in this entire process how
can she possibly talk about duty and
honor and faith in politicians when we
cannot even trust the most basic things
her ministers are saying this the world
laughing at us you're bleeding
show me the headlines show me the world
you see the world that laugh at at frogs
do ourselves down and actually I'm gonna
say this with this sweater on I think
that we often put ourselves down this
because we live in a democracy this
sometimes I think we need to step back
and see the wood for the trees now yes
we've got this difficult situation we're
in government is in deadlock
conservative parties in civil war Corbin
is Corbin and I will say despite all of
that yes we're still better than what's
going on in France burning things down
on the streets and I'm going to say that
there is still trouble with
working-class and northern
representation but it's certainly better
than most other countries where
democracies aren't representative as a
Lib Dem I do run again that's what I was
gonna say are we are democracies in our
leaders are a product of our people and
the public opinion is what led to brexit
public opinion is what led to trample is
what led to all these populist rising
actually the problem isn't the
politicians where their comments are
actually I don't know Trump would've won
had Hillary Clinton not been his
opposition tell me why you'd be awesome
in power thank you guys to you agrees
well what are we gonna you know I said
at the beginning in your introduction
write it who wants the hassle and the
headache of the constant scrutiny in
attacks sums and this why I'm now saying
what I'm saying cuz sometimes eight that
lot that we just saw get an unfair rap
you know they are only trying to deter
ease amaze only trying to deliver on
what her mandate and what the people
voted for and yeah she's making a dog's
ear of
but dogs mess of it whichever word you
want to use but at the end of the day or
dogs she's stuck and what could she do
what would we do in a position in a
discussion about what politicians are
like I mean I think quite good people go
into politics and they're not so nice
when they come out
therefore it's about the system I nearly
did many years ago break the system
produces cookie cutters because we don't
tolerate anything else if a person with
personality went in we criticize them
for having personality
we want that bog-standard Teresa made
box-style politics know the system you
may not want even a system so far in my
lifetime there and then will in my
lifetime I'm the oldest bloke long long
lifetime the world has changed beyond
recognition the political but
interestingly the world has changed
beyond recognition and the structures of
politics haven't changed at all hardly
and I think that's the real problem that
we're still we're still why you won't
get into politics because I think it you
again you you've got great experience
why wouldn't you why wouldn't I
because because you have to be too nice
to too many people to get up the ladder
right okay well on that note talking
about not being nicer you're watching
the pledge on scar knees up next how all
of us could and should be doing more to
tackle racism